je m'entretiens avec laurence grondin
robillard chercheuse au groupe de
recherche interuniversitaire sur
l'information la société la
communication et les spécialistes des
médias sociaux numériques bonsoir
d'abord c'est quoi l'intérêt de renommer
une entreprise qu'une marque de commerce
aussi forte que facebook à y en a
plusieurs premièrement avec tout ce qui
s'est passé avec la lanceuse dallaire 36
au game ça tombe plutôt bien que
facebook décide de changer le nom de sa
société mère
ça rassure les investisseurs qui venait
d'apprendre qu'ils ont beau toutes les
informations en général concernant leurs
investissements avec facebook et bien
c'est un pari que ce que valve était
prêt à prendre donc clairement il avait
un bénéfice à le faire mais ça va nous
permettre d'aller chercher d'autres
formes d'entreprises de projets autres
que l'idée de ce 60e donc on parle de
jeux vidéo peut-être davantage de
développements technologiques etc donc
on vient changer un peu le message
aujourd'hui aussi exactement où en est
on veut aller plus loin en valais au
delà on veut voir plus large et surtout
on veut arrêter de que les gens pensent
que facebook ça s'arrête facebook les
médias justement la réalité virtuelle il
est prévu que ça vienne retirer 10
milliards de dollars au profit
opérationnel sur des revenus totaux de
117 milliards cette année pour pour
facebook seulement à rechercher en
développement c'est énorme pour le métal
le méta univers pour le bénéfice de nos
téléspectateurs qu'est ce que c'est ça
le métavers les métavers ces mêmes états
unis vers les universités le but de que
tout soit connecté tout le temps donc
jusqu'à ce que veulent être présenté cet
après midi c'était davantage une en face
social a été lui disais que les jours la
personnalisation d'avatar la
personnalisation de du lobby quand on
arrive dans ses méthodes à flot on peut
faire une maison de rêve un salon
devrait donc c'est vraiment très côté
loisirs vent mais sa famille qu'il va
peut être connecté tout le temps on
compte de banque amazon par ses
commandes via cet univers le foot et sa
musique envoyer ses courriels le travail
et donc elle sait vraiment plus large
que juste sur les jeux vidéo par exemple
quand on parle de réalité virtuelle de
réalité augmentée donc vous l'avez un
petit on parle d'avatar on pourrait
éventuellement avoir des réunions de
travail en mode immersif jusqu'à quel
point ça va devenir réalité tout ça
rapidement
rapidement je ne pourrais poser la
technologie est là mais ce qu'on a vu
dans la présentation s'est manqué un peu
de délai va donc aussi que ça s'en vient
mais ce que j'avais dit dans certaines
entrevues que ça te fallait juste car
sur une dizaine d'années en prendre
possession de cet univers donc tu vas
avoir des changements dans la prochaine
année mais avant que ça devient vraiment
un endroit où tout le monde votre âme
alliés est connecté avec les lunettes de
réalité augmentée par exemple on peut se
donner encore au moins une année
facilement oculus est une filiale de
facebook qui fabrique ses lunettes de
réalité virtuelle est ce que ça veut
dire caucus aura le monopole sur les
plus gros casque de réalité virtuelle
dont il faudra tous se mirent à un
moment donné si on veut prendre part à
cette réalité version puisqu'on peut pas
en si oui c'est assez incertain parce
que je veux que le site bénéficie de la
visibilité de facebook et facebook vont
essayer d'envoyer ses éducateurs
barbecue lice mais ils ont aussi passé à
une alternative un peu moins coûteuse
dans leur association avec le x10 cas
pour la marque free dan va ce match
c'est moins cher aussi pour bénéficier
de cette réalité augmentée leur ai dit
mais tu as univers sans passer
nécessairement par un recul jusqu'à quel
point il ya de la concurrence dans ce
domaine ce que facebook fait cavalier
seul omettant fait cavalier seul
pour l'instant oui on se rappellera
qu'il y ait quelqu'un dany boon avait un
peu esthétique net a été de gens de se
lancer là dedans et on en était passé à
côté le modèle des luminaires de
personnes intéresse un ca de départ
assez d'options donc les gros jouarre on
les entend peu s'il y en a c'est
vraiment une concentration sur facebook
actuellement est ce qu'une expertise à
montréal où on pourrait avoir des
écosystèmes en réalité virtuelle des
travailleurs de méthode qui pourrait
s'établir ici
des travailleurs espèrent mais oui on a
une expertise d'un script quelqu'un
qu'on a des gens que ça intéresse qui
font de la recherche ou si ce sont les
jeux vidéo et qu'ils ont des projets
aussi de réalité augmentée donc je pense
qu'on a même l expertise du strip pour
s'intéresser à sa charge évidemment tout
ce qui s'est passé dans les derniers
jours dernières semaines concernant la
confidentialité
d'un point de vue éthique est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre aux mêmes standards que
ce qu'on voit présentement sur facebook
ce qui vaut pour assurer nos
téléspectateurs une très bonne question
est effectivement que et on a un
problème de ce côté-là ici ce que fait
ce père dont il reconnaît qu'un problème
ils voulaient le changement non lieu qui
était prévu mais qui tombe plutôt à
point et ça va être facile de dire en
changeant le nom que ça c'est ce
problème là on défis que vous nommez à
partenaires facebook mais maintenant
mais la latitude est maire s'appelle
méthode donc on s'est amélioré et dans
sa vidéo il répondait vraiment point par
point ses critiques envers nous sommes
transparents nous voulons investir dans
la recherche le développement ch on a eu
beaucoup de critiques mais on s'est
améliorés donc
non je ne suis pas rassuré pour
l'instant mon contrat je pense à me
prendre plus de cadres encore plus
peut-être fait en sens inverse est
encore plus large puisque monde
présentement laurence grondin robillard
merci infiniment pour votre passage à
soir un pv
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh